we're in San Francisco home to the
on-demand economy thousands of people
here drive cars run errands deliver food
even provide dry cleaning and manicures
all for us at the touch of a button on a
scale from one to 10 how much more
convenient have these apps made your
lives
bigger than a today point two eight
point two all right we got a fraction up
in there the companies say it's a
win-win customers lives are made easier
and workers get flexible scheduling but
here's the thing those workers driving
you around or running your errands
nearly all of them are freelancers
meaning they don't get benefits vacation
or sick leave even if they work 40 hours
a week 34 percent of all US workers are
freelancers and in the next five years
it'll be an estimated 40 percent I
wanted to know all these workers making
our life super convenient are they
getting their fair share of the deal
I met a driver for uber and sidecar who
wanted to remain anonymous because he
still works for the companies I have
certain rules I have to follow in order
to continue to receive ride requests
from either service it's really not
entirely up to me what is entirely up to
me is when I work and while that's great
I don't really make the rules so to a
great extent I feel that I work for them
sure I mean it's good that they exist I
think that they should take better care
of their workers lawsuits have been
filed across the country disputing labor
practices at places like candy uber and
CrowdFlower and three over drivers have
filed a federal class-action lawsuit
against the company seeking employee
status the ultimate decision could
affect up to 160,000 drivers in
California I talked to the Rebecca Smith
from the National Employment Law Project
what risks are these workers taking by
working for the on-demand companies on a
day to day basis it's that
precariousness and the lack of stability
that makes it more difficult for workers
to come together and organize and that's
really the bedrock of workers rights how
are these on-demand companies disrupting
the labor workforce treating these
workers as independent contractors means
that all of the games made by labor made
by workers coming together in the last
century all of that is put at risk by
the on-demand economy keep in mind other
industries use freelancers too and there
are definitely people who would rather
freelance than work 9:00 to 5:00 and
some on-demand companies like uber do
offer their workers perks like discounts
on car maintenance and foam plants I
reached out to several on-demand
companies they either didn't immediately
respond or wouldn't comment on the
record but in the midst of all this
controversy some companies are doing
things differently I went to one of them
mantri the food delivery service they
classify their drivers as employees with
benefits as long as they work 30 hours
or more
what made you guys decide to turn your
independent contractors and to employees
it was really an observation that we or
in belief that we would have an easier
time recruiting people and that we would
be able to get higher quality employees
if we treated them as employees as
opposed to contract us was that proven
correct yes how do you measure that
increased productivity really more than
anything else we have a number of
drivers who have been with us for many
years they get very good at their routes
they get to know their customers their
customers get comfortable with them and
we think that causes people to order
more frequently from us
so there you have it these apps are
changing the workforce a lot of them are
depending on freelancers and some of
them are going back to more traditional
models but at the end of the day who
will thrive and what's fair to workers